douze ans qu'ils viennent au festival de
cannes leur première c'était ensemble
cette année encore gaëlle pineau élue
beaucamp sont venus à deux pour une
semaine de cinéma
un moment qui compte pour eux une bulle
d'oxygène dans leur quotidien
d'exploitants de salles
en tant que voisin on travaille
régulièrement ensemble on discute
beaucoup et de venir ici c'est on a les
mêmes informations en même temps on
prend du temps aussi ensemble on mange
ensemble régulièrement d'aurensan pas
dans le même lit mais dans le même
appartement
non mais c'est un moment de convivialité
aussi pour nous qui est vachement
important aux années de travail au
programme de la semaine rencontres et
réunions avec les autres responsables
des cinémas art et essai beaucoup de
films aussi pour assister à des
projections accessible grâce à une
accréditation et des invitations avec en
moyenne 1h30 d'attenté devant les salles
pendant toute l'année on regarde pas
autant le film que ça pourtant des
programmateurs donc beaucoup connaissent
un maximum donc là on fait le plein le
plein le plein de films pour ce 62e
festival luc et gaëlle ont vu une
vingtaine de films de la sélection
officielle à la semaine de la critique
trois ont particulièrement retenu leur
attention cette année on en parle on a
un peu les mêmes coups de coeur c'est
vrai qu'il ya papicha un film qui se
passe en algérie pendant les années 90
on a beaucoup aimé dessus mais là et
c'est sûr que attrape il sera il sera
projeté il ya aussi et aussi les
misérables de la sbee et puis aussi un
très beau film d'animation qui s'appelle
j'ai perdu mon corps qui à mon avis sera
primé parce que magnifique superbe film
qu'on a vu des coups de coeur que l'on
devrait retrouver dans les salles du
ciné 7 et du grenier à sel dans les
prochains mois